l'enquète sur le drame du crs du 19e
arrondissement pourrait bien mettre en
cause les matières employées pour la
construction de l'établissement
il ya d'abord les témoignages d'une
anime sur l'extrême rapidité avec
laquelle le feu s'est propagé
il n'y a rien d'officiel mais les
enquêteurs auraient noté la mauvaise
qualité des cloisons fait de blocs
d'agglo mad aggloméré séparé selon
certains commentaires par des plaques de
matières plastiques bien sûr cela n'a
rien à voir avec l'origine de la 110
mais les matériaux utilisés devraient
pouvoir supporter les flammes pendant un
temps minimum nous avons pu poser ce
matin quelques questions au président
directeur général de la société qui
construit les crs de ce type
monsieur le fait vous être pdg de la
société qui avait choisi les matériaux
qui ont servi à la construction du cs
edouard peillon a reproché fait face à
des accusations sont faites on prétend
qu'il y à du plastique dans ses cloisons
qu'en est il exactement et bien c'est
exact que c'est notre société qui
choisit les matériaux qu'ils doivent
être utilisés dans ce système et qui les
soumet ensuite à l'agrément du ministère
de la construction
je démens formellement qu'il y ait la
moindre parcelle de plastique dans ses
cloisons ses cloisons sont constitués
par des panneaux de fibres de bois
aggloméré de 35 mm de 50 mm d'épaisseur
ces panneaux sont accouplés deux par
deux pour former une cloison 264 mm
d'épaisseur
à l'intérieur il y à un vide est
absolument aucun plastique la résistance
au feu contrôlé par le laboratoire est
de 1h ou 1h30 ou même deux heures
suivant l'épaisseur de chacune des
contrepoison là un enduit effet au four
cet enduit est absolument un combustible
ces matériaux sont agréés par le centre
scientifique et technique du bâtiment
comme difficilement
inflammable après avoir été testé ces
matériaux sont commandés chez certains
fournisseurs par nos soins nous nous
assurerons sur le chantier que ces mêmes
matériaux sont livrés par les
fournisseurs conforme à notre demande du
reste enquêtes en cours fait des
prélèvements qui démontreront absolument
le bien fondé de ces affirmations
monsieur lesage jour merci à vous
cognacq jay au loyer selon les
accusations dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure la polémique n'est pas terminé
il faudra surtout expliquer bien sûr la
rapidité d'extension du feu surtout si
les matériaux ne sont pas en cause comme
on vient de nous le dire
je vous rappelle que l' incendie a fait
22 morts le corps d'un professeur n'a
d'ailleurs pas encore été retrouvé ce
matin les parents des victimes devaient
se réunir pour examiner la possibilité
de créer une association afin de faire
valoir le droit des familles il ya aussi
en marge de ce drame des incendies
criminels qui s'était déclaré jeudi dans
deux collèges d'enseignement secondaire
de la région parisienne on peut pour
l'instant que les attribuer à des
déséquilibrés ou à des personnes qui
voudraient faire croire à la thèse de
l'attentât pour le crs du 19e
arrondissement